[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
Ecuador debutó a lo grande la selección
de la mitad del mundo superó en el
primer partido del torneo a la
representación de Qatar el resultado es
un paso importante para el grupo que
dirige Gustavo Alfaro te avanzar a la
siguiente fase tenemos análisis
[Música]
Karim Benzema se lesionó el músculo de
una de sus piernas y se perderá lo que
hubiese sido su segunda Copa del Mundo
este domingo se conoció que el
entrenador de champs no reemplazará al
jugador en la lista de 26 tenemos
reacciones
[Música]
la selección de Países Bajos comenzará
su andar en Qatar este lunes cuando
enfrente a la selección de senegal está
la naranja mecánica para buscar su
primer título en la copa del mundo
tenemos análisis previo al partido
[Música]
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio osaso periodista de la emisora
radial Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido
Octavio un gusto un gusto poder
compartir contigo con toda la gente de
France 24 y por supuesto muy feliz de
comenzar la fiesta de la Copa del Mundo
Así es esperamos tanto tiempo También
aprovecho para darle la bienvenida a
nuestro enviado especial Juan pupiales
quien nos trae todos los detalles de
primera mano de lo que ocurre en Qatar
saludos Juan buenas noches para ti Bueno
ya madrugada allá en Qatar
Hola Luis qué tal si ya casi un nuevo
día aquí en Qatar aquí después de ese
triunfo histórico para Sudamérica un
triunfo histórico porque por primera vez
en la historia de un partido inaugural
de un mundial a selección anfitriona ha
perdido
bueno Y así empezamos porque poco más de
cuatro años transcurrieron desde que
Francia venció a Croacia y alzó la copa
del mundo en Rusia 2018 cuatro años
pasaron y otros ocho más con polémica y
cuestionamientos pero este 20 de
noviembre Qatar recibió el primer torneo
de la copa del mundo en el medio oriente
el partido inaugural se llevó a cabo
entre las elecciones de Qatar local y
cómo se viene desarrollando desde el
mundial de Alemania en 2006 se midió a
la representación de Ecuador Ecuador que
si bien el técnico rival le dio el
cartel de favorito llegaba al partido
con dos situaciones de contra una
surgida hace unos meses cuando debió
planificar un partido con un día menos
de antelación y la situación vivida
luego de culminar las eliminatorias
sudamericanas por el tema de Byron
Castillo jugador que al final no pudo
formar parte de la plantilla ecuatoriana
Juan aprovecho para consultarte qué
detalles podemos referir de Este triunfo
ecuatoriano en la presente de la copa
del mundo
se notó desde un comienzo Luis a un
equipo ecuatoriano que tenía mucha más
experiencia y que trabajaba mucho más en
equipo desde el primer momento de
Ecuador presionó mucho más arriba ante
una Qatar que estaba muy nerviosa Tenía
mucho miedo se notó muchísimo la presión
y eso que no había precisamente un
ambiente de Gran partido de eso
hablaremos más adelante en este
encuentro sin embargo desde un comienzo
de Ecuador salió con demasiada reservas
Qatar salió eh catar salió con muchas
reservas frente a un ecuador que salió a
dominar el encuentro y además siendo
fiel a su Estilo el juego por las bandas
algo que han dejado muy en evidencia en
las eliminatorias sudamericanas balones
largos buscando esos centros y así llegó
así llegaron los goles de este partido
además con la complicidad del portero
chavín de
Qatar que terminó cediendo y terminó
además en este contexto con el que saltó
Qatar con esa Falta de confianza se
encontraron con un Portero que ya los
tres minutos había demostrado que no
estaba bien por arriba y eso se notó
demasiado el segundo gol de Ecuador
llegó desde un saque de banda de Qatar
que termine en ese gol de en ese segundo
gol de Ender Valencia a tener Valencia
como no Superman grandísimo protagonista
de la jornada de hoy hombre del partido
de hoy dos goles para vender Valencia
máximo goleador histórico de Ecuador un
hombre que destacó muchísimo hoy de la
mano también de Angelo Preciado de
Gonzalo plata de permiso estupiñán un
conjunto ecuatoriano que hubiese mostró
de verdad con mucha experiencia y sobre
todo con una sensación de ser un equipo
que ya juega con mucha identidad algo
que ha conseguido en casi que un tiempo
récord el profesor Gustavo Alfaro lo
importante de este resultado de Ecuador
también es que regresan los goles a la
selección de la mitad del mundo luego de
esos partidos amistosos donde no había
podido marcar pero Octavio si bien
Ecuador sentía o tenía esa
responsabilidad de ganar el partido era
de esperar la manera como lo hizo que
incluso llevó a Gustavo Alfaro a
modificar su planteamiento técnico Y
colocar a dos jugadores de similares
características en el frente ofensivo Sí
el tenía claro que que catar más allá de
ser una selección que había estado
concentrado durante mucho tiempo y que
tenía una ventaja por el resto de los
países que era esa misma situación de no
tener jugadores en el extranjero de
poder contar con la mayoría del grupo
disponibles desde hace mucho tiempo
Gustavo Alfaro sabía que era su gran
momento Para pasarle por encima y
conseguir una victoria que no solo le
diera Este triunfo histórico por primera
vez a un equipo en la inauguración
frente al equipo local sino que además
le permitiera de él soñar con la
clasificación en la mayoría de los
partidos de la fase de grupos Porque
estos tres puntos le van a permitir a
Ecuador manejarse con cierta
tranquilidad y aquí en adelante Entonces
él utilizó la posibilidad de jugar con
los dos de arriba dándole libertad de
inervalencia que es la gran figura de
este equipo y el capitán y fue el que
terminó consiguiendo la victoria Más
allá de que luego salió con algunos
problemas de lesión pero Ecuador tenía
la obligación de ganar y de ganar de
manera contundente incluso creo que
Gustavo Alfaro luego se lamenta de que
el partido no haya terminado con una con
una goleada o cantidad de goles más a su
favor porque evidentemente era la gran
oportunidad para que el equipo
sudamericano pudiese llevarse una
ventaja holgada creo que Ecuador terminó
sacando el resultado que quería que
necesitaba y dejando en claro que es un
equipo mucho más fuerte que la selección
catarín que evidentemente no está al
nivel del equipo de Alfaro y
precisamente vamos a hablar ahora de esa
selección de Qatar un conjunto que viene
trabajando por el largo tiempo juntos se
pararon su liga o la culminaron en el
mes de mayo para poder pensar y
enfocarse en la copa del mundo que está
en su territorio también Vienen
trabajando el hecho de participar en
torneo fuera de Asia como lo es el caso
de la Copa América en el año 2019 y
también la participación en la copa de
oro de la Concacaf donde llegaron a
semifinales por esos resultados por el
tiempo trabajado
Qatar tenía la obligación de por lo
menos rescatar un punto en este partido
sí obviamente cuando uno ve el equipo
Luis Sánchez y uno entiende que jugaron
la Copa América que jugaron la Copa Oro
que tienen todas este este tiempo juntos
uno podía entender que era un equipo que
en principio se conocía o se conoce muy
bien y que podía sacarle algo de ventaja
a esa esa posibilidad de ser
prácticamente el único país que está
concentrado hace meses a diferencia del
resto de las elecciones Sin embargo a la
hora de competir por los puntos de
competir mano a mano con jugadores más
experimentados eso incluso Ecuador es
prácticamente cener Valencia el único
jugador con experiencia mundialista pero
sus jugadores están todos en ligas
importantes la mayoría de ellos juegan
eliminatorias sudamericanas y Qatar no
tiene ese roce por un lado está El hecho
de tener una selección de laboratorio
pero al ir a pelear mano a mano contra
rivales de más experiencia de más Rodas
en cuanto al tema futbolístico le costó
Y eso se notó evidentemente
Qatar tuvo un par de posibilidades yo
creo que incluso una de ellas pudo haber
entrado para para marcar una diferencia
cortar al resultado y quizás eso hubiese
podido cambiar la dinámica del partido
sin embargo Qatar yo creo que incluso
Qatar no no mostró el buen fútbol que
mostró en la Copa Oro por ejemplo
excepcionó un poco Qatar le costó eso
pensamos que Qatar podía jugar mejor y
al final le pasa factura el hecho de que
sus jugadores no tengan ese ese roce
frente a un rival que fue que fue que
jugó una muy buena eliminatoria y que
tiene evidentemente mucho más recorrido
y al final le termina dando la razón al
seleccionador del conjunto catarín El
Español Félix Sánchez de El favorito
para este partido era Ecuador pero Juan
aplastes hace unos minutos atrás de el
ambiente como se percibió en torno a la
selección local Y cómo asimilaron este
resultado
Mira estaba hablando antes con un colega
cataría ese Pobre hombre no le cabía él
no se le no podía demostrar más
decepción en su rostro me decía llevamos
mucho tiempo esperando por eso y me
decía no jugamos a nada no les puedo
explicar la expectativa que había en
este país por ese partido de hoy como lo
dijo el profesor Gustavo Alfaro ayer
Qatar lleva 12 años llevaba 12 años
preparándose para el partido de hoy la
mayoría de los jugadores que vimos de la
selección de Qatar son formados en la
academia aspire ese centro o ese súper
centro de alto rendimiento que se formó
en 2014 la mayoría de ellos fueron
seleccionados desde niños para integrar
esa selección catari como ya lo
comentaban con Octavio a través de un
proceso muy cuidado para tener rosas
internacionales todo esto para el
partido de hoy y me decían algunos
cataríes incluso hablábamos con no
cantarías con residencias de aquí que
nos estaban comentando hasta hace unos
momentos teníamos una expectativa muy
grande y ahora nos quedamos con una
expectativa de que vimos un nivel que no
era el que esperábamos y el escenario
ahora no es bueno porque encima se viene
y se viene Países Bajos además pasó algo
en el estadio que fue demasiado
llamativo primero Cuando llegamos a este
estadio el estado de al 20 notamos desde
el primer comienzo Esta es un estadio
que está muy lejos a unos 35 kilómetros
de aquí de dohan desde nuestra llegada
del estadio ya el ambiente era muy frío
Nosotros somos latinoamericanos cuando
vamos un estadio el ambiente es distinto
obviamente son culturas muy distintas la
de Qatar y la que podemos tener por
ejemplo en Colombia desde que llegamos
notamos Esa frialdad cuando ingresamos
el estadio comprobamos que era algo muy
distinto de la afición catari obviamente
mayoría solamente reaccionaba ante las
jugadas de peligro y prácticamente que
no había un ambiente para un partido
inaugural de un mundial nosotros
volviendo a hacer esa comparación con
los equipos latinos Cuando juega un
equipo latino prácticamente que el país
se paraliza yo me crié en España en
España por ejemplo también pasa lo mismo
juega la selección Española y en un
mundial el país entero está con esto
aquí después del 2 a 0 de Ecuador la
gente empezó a irse del estadio para el
descanso mucha gente se fue cuando se
reanudó el partido en la segunda parte
había muchos claros en la grada y ella
llegó un dato el cual estábamos
comentando con los compañeros este
estadio el estado de albate tiene una
capacidad según la FIFA para 60.000
personas según el dato de la FIFA
acudieron 67.000 personas que ya estamos
hablando de un desfase de 7000
aficionados que estamos viendo que puede
que en algún momento hayan estado
superando la capacidad original del
estadio pero no es un dato que refleja
para nada el ambiente que vivimos y que
para los aficionados del Fútbol pues nos
queda esa deuda de bueno si ese es el
ambiente que vimos en el partido
inaugural que nos espera entonces en los
otros encuentros y un dato demográfico
Juan un estadio de 60.000 espectadores
para una población que apenas sobrepasa
los 30.000 pero es interesante hablar de
este proceso de
Qatar 2022 y sobre todo lo que se llevó
a cabo previo al partido porque
alrededor de las 17 horas locales en la
mañana para Europa y en América algunos
países del hemisferio occidental ya con
bien entrada a la tarde fue la
inauguración la misma destacó aspectos
de la cultura catari como era de esperar
y presentó un emotivo momento recordando
las mascotas de las copas mundiales
pasadas además contó con la presencia de
entre otros el actor estadounidense
Morgan Freeman y del creador de
contenido canning al Mustang pero Juan
hablando Ya de esta situación Cómo se
vivieron los actos protocolares en el
estadio albeita
sí la inauguración fue un momento
también muy esperado sin embargo para
ese momento para la inauguración todavía
el estadio no estaba lleno al completo
yo soy una persona que piensa que las
inauguraciones en el mundo del fútbol no
sé por qué por alguna razón en especial
nunca brillan todos nos acordamos de las
inauguraciones en los Juegos Olímpicos
nos acordamos de Barcelona 92 nos
acordamos de la inauguración de los
Juegos Olímpicos eran del fútbol no
terminan de brillar la organización la
inauguración de fue una organización muy
preparada y se trajeron a los mejores
organizadores del mundo que precisamente
organizadores creadores que han estado
en inauguraciones en ceremonias de los
Juegos Olímpicos fue una ceremonia que
le aplaudo en mi caso personal
precisamente ese recorrido por los otros
mundiales hubo también un recorrido por
las canciones por los signos del mundial
es además para mí sonaron de manera
consecutiva los dos mejores himnos que
ha habido en la historia de los
mundiales la copa de la vida de Ricky
Martin de 1998 y el Waka waka de Shakira
en 2010 fue todo Pesado en hacer como
una especie de el recorrido también una
especie en un momento cultural así
comenzó esta ceremonia inaugural con ese
discurso de Morgan Freeman liderado por
Morgan Freeman y también se notó
obviamente mucho despliegue de fuegos de
artificio de láser un spliegue
tecnológico importante con el que Qatar
quiso Pues también mostrarse al mundo
tenemos que darle un contexto muy
importante a la gente que es que
Qatar estuvo Hasta el año pasado
bloqueado por varios países vecinos
árabes aquí en la región y para acatar
este evento es una oportunidad casi que
única para mostrarse al mundo como un
lugar como una potencia en el mundo
árabe y ahí que para ellos sea tan
importante este evento llevan desde 2010
cuando fueron elegidos como sede este
mundial oficialmente preparándose pero
rescatar lleva muchos años más buscando
un evento de esta magnitud porque son un
país pequeño son un poquito más grande
que Jamaica Pero ellos quieren Mostrar
que tiene una capacidad sobre todo para
brillar a través del deporte y también
pues para mostrarse de esa manera que
sea otra Qatar que no se hable siempre
de las catar polémica de la catar que
venimos hablando en nuestras emisiones
en nuestro noticiero desacatar que tiene
denuncias por malos tratos que tiene
denuncias por restricciones contra la
comunidad lgtbico más porque tiene
denuncias por las por los obreros que
murieron en la construcción de esos
estadios por ello ha sido Octavio una
copa del mundo muy muy polémica sobre
todo desde su elección era la opción más
indicada para llevar a cabo una copa del
mundo no lo que pasa es que claro en el
libro de requerimientos de Fifa hay un
par de detalles que no los tiene catar
que es haber tenido al menos experiencia
o tener un crecimiento en cuanto al
fútbol local tener algún tipo de
relación con eventos importantes eso
lamentablemente catarnos no lo tenía
evidentemente esta esta decisión fue más
allá de eso rompió los paradigmas de de
las elecciones de la manera en Cómo se
vienen escogiendo los mundiales de
fútbol y evidentemente es un es un
mundial atípico ya el simple hecho de
que las personas puedan presenciar un
par de partidos o tres partidos en un
mismo día una misma persona que puedan
moverse en en metro de un estadio al
otro que les puedan permitir ese tipo de
avances tecnológicos ya ya cambia
totalmente la dinámica de juego cuando
normalmente los mundiales se termina un
partido en una ciudad y hay una ciudad
muy lejana en donde se va a jugar el
otro Hay un montón de situaciones que
tienen que ver con eso evidentemente
quizás no era la mejor elección pero a
partir de eso estamos hablando de un
mundial que lo va a marcar la tecnología
que lo va a marcar el despliegue y que
en función de eso arrancará precisamente
el día de hoy y veremos Cómo se
desarrolla a lo largo de los próximos
días y qué nos permite ver este mundial
entre comillas artificial que vamos a
empezar a observar a partir de hoy
Octavio lo importante que mencionas el
tema de la tecnología de hecho ya lo
empezamos a ver en ese primer partido
entre
Qatar y Ecuador sobre todo el uso de la
herramienta tecnológica para detectar lo
que tiene que ver con las adelantadas o
lo fuera de juego pero hablando de la
elección de Qatar como bien lo apuntado
Octavio es necesario tener una cultura
de fútbol para tener una idea desde la
primera Copa del Mundo realizada en
Uruguay en 1930 los países que
albergaron este torneo terminan cierta
tradición por el deporte porque luego de
esa copa del mundo en Uruguay se llevó a
cabo una en Italia en 1934 y Francia en
1938 entre 1938 y 1950 no se pudo
disputar por la guerra pero entre 1950 y
1970 se fue alternando entre Europa y
América del Sur hasta que llegó México
en
1970 de allí nuevamente la copa pasa a
Europa Estados Unidos 1994 y de allí da
ese salto esa experiencia que quería yo
ser blatter para expandir la fronteras
del fútbol y en este caso pudo en
conseguirse esa Copa del Mundo 2012 en
Corea y Japón y más tarde en el año 2010
en el Sudáfrica en el continente
africano pero estamos hablando de un
proceso que requiere un trabajo
exhaustivo de preparación no solo para
conformar los estadios a utilizarse sino
también en cuanto a las personas que
estarán trabajando como voluntarios y
así guiar a los miles de visitantes que
acuden para presenciar este evento
aprovechó para entonces consultarte Juan
a nivel organizativo qué impresiones les
ha dejado Este primer día en la copa del
mundo
Luis por favor me puede repetir la
pregunta te consultaba sobre el tema
organizativo que le deja qué impresiones
les deja Este primer día de la copa del
mundo
nos ha dejado por lo menos a la prensa
una impresión muy negativa porque es el
primer día es la primera vez que un país
tan pequeño organiza un mundial y por lo
menos Hoy concretamente tuvimos además
el estadio como respeto el estadio más
lejano que tenemos en esta copa mundo
casi toda la copa mundo transcurre en
los alrededores de dos Hoy tuvimos que
hacer un camino más o menos de unos 40 a
45 minutos hasta el estado de Albert que
está muy lejano tanto la idea como el
regreso fue una verdadera fue muy
complicado para los periodistas en el
regreso había una fila enormes de
periodistas que tuvimos que esperar una
hora después del final del partido para
regresar tenemos el antecedente de lo
que ocurrió ayer en la fansón en la zona
de fanáticos que hubo más hubo más
personas de la capacidad que tenía esa
fanzón hubo además esas quejas de que
hubo una respuesta muy agresiva y muy
negativa por parte de las autoridades es
la nota negativa que nos está dejando de
momento este mundial de Qatar 2022 pero
lo cierto es que en las calles todo es
nuevo el metro es prácticamente nuevo
Hay que decir también que se puede ir en
metro prácticamente a todos los estadios
salvo el de Albert es algo que ellos
destacan y lo hemos comprobado y es algo
agradable el metro además es gratuito
por estas fechas las distancias son
cortas pero bueno ya nos quedamos muchos
periodistas con el primer día con lo que
nos ocurrió hoy queda muchísimo mundial
es un mundial de 29 días Apenas llevamos
el primero se vienen unas jornadas que
van a ser históricas como mencionaba
Octavio porque nunca antes habíamos
tenido cuatro partidos en un mismo día
se puede por primera vez en el estudio
de un mundial viajar cómodamente ir
hasta a dos partidos y hasta un
aficionado que tenga lo tenga muy bien
planeado hasta tres partidos al día
puede venir en esta copa mundo vamos a
ver cómo avanza aquí no se habla de otra
cosa este país está completamente
volcado con esta copa mundo de Qatar no
hay otro tema Cuando se habla con las
personas aquí dice es lo único de lo que
se habla obviamente
pero tenemos que pasar a un tema
lamentable Juan y es que la copa del
mundo se queda sin el ganador del Balón
de Oro 44 años después de que Alan
simonsen no pudiese participar en el
Torneo que se llevó a cabo en Argentina
en el año de 1978 El delantero de la
selección francesa y el Real Madrid
Karim Benzema se perderá la copa del
mundo que hubiese sido su segunda
participación en este tipo de torneo
debido a una lesión lo confirmó la
selección francesa el pasado día sábado
a través de un comunicado donde explica
que el jugador Presenta una lesión en el
cuádriceps de su pierna izquierda en el
texto le desean una pronta recuperación
Benzema había sido parte del
entrenamiento el día sábado junto a
Rafael barán eran la novedad de ese
entrenamiento porque vale recordar que
ambos jugadores entre otros habían
presentado molestias físicas en sus
clubes Durante los últimos partidos el
diario el equipo fue el primero en
reportar la noticia sobre la situación
de
y en el mensaje en ese momento indicaba
que podría perderse el primer partido
contra Australia previsto para el 22 de
noviembre vale recordar que Francia es
una de las elecciones que más se ha
visto afectada por el tema de las
lesiones ya que pensé más se suma una
lista de jugadores que incluya entre
otros a Paul Pogba y angoló kanté
Benzema en lo que va de temporada
anotado seis goles en 12 partidos
oficiales siete de ellos por la liga
española el jugador luego de ello
escribió en su cuenta de Twitter que
nunca se ha rendido pero debe pensar en
el equipo y la razón le indica que debe
ceder su lugar a alguien para ayudar a
hacer un buen mundial a la selección
francesa sobre este tema veamos el
siguiente reportaje una adaptación
preparada por Andrés granadillo
un golpe para el equipo francés terminó
Qatar para Karim Benzema el delantero no
jugará ningún partido del mundial estoy
muy triste por Karim que había hecho de
este mundial un objetivo importante a
pesar de este nuevo golpe para el equipo
francés tengo plena confianza en mi
grupo Vamos a hacer todo lo posible para
superar el enorme reto que nos espera
sin embargo el sábado todo había
empezado bien para el número 19 por
primera vez en doha había participado en
la formación colectiva el jugador
parecía estar en buena forma pero
rápidamente tuvo que abandonar el campo
el motivo un dolor en el cuádriceps
izquierdo por la noche llegó El
veredicto una lesión muscular que
requiere una convalecencia de tres
semanas a sus 34 años Karim Benzema
probablemente no volverá a jugar un
mundial el ganador del Balón de oro de
2022 expresó su pesar en Twitter en mi
vida nunca me he rendido pero esta noche
tengo que pensar en el equipo como
siempre lo he hecho así que la razón me
dice que el lugar a alguien que pueda
ayudar a nuestro grupo a ser un buen
mundial Gracias por todos sus mensajes
de apoyo este mundial empieza muy mal
para el equipo francés algunos ya hablan
de la maldición del campeón las
ausencias ya eran numerosas Paul Pogba
en golocanté Presley o Christopher en
cunco líder de Sam tiene que revisar sus
planes una vez más todavía tiene unas
horas para convocar a otro jugador antes
del primer partido de leblé El martes
por la noche contra Australia
pero sin duda la elección de Karim
Benzema ha sido la noticia en la previa
de el inicio de esta copa del mundo para
ampliar detalles sobre el impacto que ha
tenido la misma el periodista Nino
mangravita de la redacción de Tigo Sport
en Panamá nos ofrece el siguiente
análisis
Qué tal amigos Cómo están un placer
saludarles cenino mangravita de Tigo
Sports aquí en Ciudad de Panamá bueno el
tema Benzema es un tema caliente es un
tema que que le está dando la vuelta al
mundo por encima de cualquier otro en
estos momentos pero yo creo que didier
de champs sé que es una persona muy muy
astuta lo fue como jugador y también lo
es como director técnico ya lo venía
contemplando el De seguro ya tenía un
plan b para esta situación y y en efecto
Francia ha tenido bajas posiblemente la
selección con más baja de esta Copa
Mundial y son bajas muy importantes muy
puntuales o sea canté
un cucú
Pogba ahora Benzema o sea son jugadores
que lo más probable iban a ser titulares
Aquí es donde viene el el Plan B y
Francia tiene jugadores para poder por
lo menos arrancar este torneo y que vaya
evolucionando a medida que vayan pasando
de ronda y que se vayan dando los
partidos tocará ahora a giro de seguro
arriba con mbappé con griezmann con
dembélé con rabiote un poco más
o sea van a haber cambios de
nombres que posiblemente no se tenían
contemplado y esos son los huecos que
empezarán a llenar el hueco de Benzema
es muy grande Benzema ha aportado
muchísimo un jugador que se tiró
prácticamente junto a courtois También
tienen mucho que ver en la en el título
ese del Real Madrid en la Champions Hace
algunos meses pero repito o sea son
jugadores muy importantes Pero los que
vienen detrás de ellos o lo que están
junto a él son jugadores que tienen
muchas cualidades también para poder
seguir teniendo a Francia como uno de
los top candidatos para esta Copa
Mundial
Octavio desde el punto de vista anímico
porque sabemos que Francia cuenta con
otras figuras que pudiesen reemplazar a
Benzema y mantener el nivel que ha
mostrado líder de cómo pudiese afectar a
la selección en esta Copa del Mundo No
no ha sido un golpe durísimo incluso los
jugadores esta mañana lo comentaban
Eduardo camavinga algún otro jugador que
habla con la prensa sobre lo que
significa es el líder del grupo y todo
el mundo estaba esperando dentro del
plantel que Benzema tuviese la revancha
de poder jugar el mundial y ganar el
mundial porque Francia gana el mundial
se invense más por toda la situación que
había tenido que lo había apartado de la
selección y era el gran momento para el
hombre del Real Madrid de poder ganar
con este grupo La copa del mundo porque
evidentemente siguen siendo grandes
favoritos para llevárselo entonces
perder a Benzema es un golpe durísimo Ya
ellos habían perdido en golo canté que
es un valor arte fundamental de la mitad
agua Pogba que anima muchísimo al grupo
pero perder al líder al cabeza al hombre
más importante del plantel y al
delantero o al jugador de mayor forma
que Francia en el equipo es algo que no
va a poder sustituir de todas maneras
Francia tiene la experiencia reciente de
haber ganado un mundial sin él y de
poder jugar sin él futbolísticamente
hablando es una cosa pero anímicamente
otra porque evidentemente estamos
hablando del hombre que prácticamente el
mundo entero quería ver pelear mano a
mano con Messi la posibilidad de jugar
un por el título de ganar el mundial de
fútbol con cristiano con las grandes
figuras y todo el mundo estaba esperando
eso Entonces que se lo pierda Es
realmente un golpe muy duro para para el
grupo y además repetimos el ganador del
Balón de Oro pero Juan cómo se ha
desarrollado la noticia en territorio
catari desde la noche allá en ese país
que explotó la misma
[Música]
nos tomó por sorpresa esa noticia
teníamos una parte de nuestro equipo
cubriendo precisamente ese entrenamiento
de la selección francesa cuando vimos
que Benzema se retiraba estuvimos desde
entonces muy pendientes comenzaron a
salir los reportes de la confirmación
por parte del equipo de Francia no llegó
pasada la medianoche mientras escuchamos
de fondo un poco del ambiente de este
mundial de Qatar aquí en doha ha sido
algo muy comentado y desde entonces
ahora todo mundo ya tiene una especie de
Aura negativa en torno lo que pueda
pasar con Francia hoy camavenga nos
entrenó por a cuidarlo dicen desde la
selección francesa y obviamente allá
entonces un mar de dudas sobre lo que
pueda pasar con la selección sobre todo
en esa parte del medio campo que nos
cuentan y con canté ni con Pogba como
estaban contando Y en donde en teoría
están llamados a tener ahora un papel
protagónico protagónico jugadores como
camavingao como strowman y que son muy
jóvenes además de radio Por ejemplo que
no ha tenido no ha sido una figura
constante en la selección francesa
muchas dudas en torno a Francia la
gracia Debut contra Australia también en
la defensa en la defensa barán tiene que
estar muy bien es el carpeta en el
capitán en defensa es el jugador más
experimentado en la defensa gran parte
de esa estabilidad de Francia pasa
porque Rafael vagan se encuentre bien
parece Debut el martes contra Australia
mucha expectativa para ese partido
entonces en territorio catarí pero a
continuación damos un repaso a la agenda
de partidos para este inicio de semana
por el grupo a la selección de Países
Bajos comienza su andar en el Torneo la
selección dirigida por Miss vanguard
debuta frente a senegal selección que
llega golpeada por la ausencia de sadio
Mané
también este día lunes abre el grupo b
De hecho el partido entre Inglaterra e
Irán será el que abra la jornada en
general mientras que Estados Unidos
frente a gales cerrará la misma en horas
de la tarde para América
[Música]
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
diario el mundial por el día de hoy
continúen con más de la programación de
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]